over the weekend we got some bombshell
leaks about apple's upcoming imac pro
including just about the most confusing
leak we've had in months which basically
came out of nowhere and shocked everyone
in the apple world according to dylan
dkt we're gonna be receiving some new
products at apple spring event like the
new high-end mac mini the new 5g iphone
se and the new ipad air all of which
were expected and i covered all of that
in my last spring event leaks video and
while i strongly believe that we'll be
seeing the high-end imac at the spring
event as well dylan says that it's on
track for a spring release but he has
heard some concerns with regards to
production which isn't a good sign but
the really confusing and downright
shocking leak from dylan was when he
said that he received confirmation about
an additional 12 core cpu chip
configuration for the upcoming imac pro
and this is shocking because this is the
first time we're hearing anything about
this since the only thing we're
currently going off of is the fact that
the m1 max chip has a secret die to die
interconnect at the bottom of the die
which is something that apple completely
hid from us in their own die images and
what we were expecting was for apple to
take two of those dies and connect them
through the new interconnect to create
an m1 max duo chip that is essentially
two times more powerful while having
double the ram double the thunderbolt
controllers double the encoders double
the everything and this route makes the
most sense for apple financially because
they don't have to spend a bunch of cash
redesigning a completely new larger die
they just take two existing dies and put
them together saving them a ton of cash
so when i heard this 12 core chip leak i
was honestly flabbergasted but i've been
doing a lot of thinking over the weekend
about how this could be possible and i
think i finally figured it out but just
to give the situation the benefit of the
doubt i'm gonna be presenting three
different scenarios for how this 12
chord chip could make sense so with that
said let's start off with the first
scenario that apple did in fact create a
brand new 12 core die that was intended
for apple's higher end desktop machines
like the imac pro so one might think
that since this is a desktop computer it
doesn't really need efficiency cores
since it won't be battery powered so
what if apple would literally just give
it 12 performance cores instead of just
8 with the m1 pro and max chips this
move by itself would give the imac pro
roughly 50 more cpu performance and it
would allow it to stay very competitive
with intel's new alder lake chips and
now that i think about it the very first
leak we got concerning the first apple
silicon chip was actually of a 12 core
chip and that was way back in the summer
of 2020 before the original m1 was
revealed so when the m1 came and it was
only an 8 chord chip it was pretty
confusing so maybe apple decided to hold
off on that special 12 core chip for
this new imac pro well honestly that
doesn't really make sense to me and
there are actually a few things that
don't make sense about this scenario in
my opinion first of all if apple did
create a new 12 core chip just for the
desktop machines then why are all of the
leaks and rumors pointing to the new mac
mini coming with the m1 pro and max
chips which is something that dylan dkt
is very sure about right now and then
going further apple developing a 12 core
chip just for the imac pro alone doesn't
make any sense because it would be
extremely expensive and the thing is
mark german has already confirmed that
the upcoming apple silicon mac pro will
have high performance 20 or 40 core
chips created by literally combining 10
core m1 max dies either two or four of
them together but if the new 12 core
chip for the imac pro was real wouldn't
apple prefer to just take those new 12
core dies and combine them together
instead to create even more powerful 24
or 48 chord chips instead of reusing the
m1 max dies that have the extra
efficiency cores that don't really
matter so with that said a new 12 core
die just for the imac pro doesn't really
make a lot of sense and there's also the
question of what they would call it for
marketing sake so i honestly am having a
hard time believing the first scenario
but it's definitely a possibility now on
to the second scenario what if this new
12 chord chip configuration is actually
a 20 core m1 max duo chip that is just
extremely bend down with eight of the
cores disabled because of floss well
this is a possibility but it would
require a very weird amount of
efficiency cores and performance course
to make sense like for example only five
peak cores within each die and just one
e core from each die which sounds very
odd now fred the frenchie on twitter
made a good point about the cost of
creating a new 5 nanometer soc which
would be over 500 million dollars in
research and development so because of
that he believes the 12 core chip is
still made from the m1 max duo because
just making a new one would be too
expensive but i personally think that
this would just be way too much chip
binning for it to make sense bringing a
20 core down to a 12 so i don't think
that a 12 core is gonna be part of the
m1 max duo at all and now with that said
it's time for the third scenario what if
this 12 core chip configuration is
actually a very early software leak for
an imac pro coming in the future like
for example that time back in july of
2020 when nine to five mac found
references to face id within mac os beta
code proving that it is in fact coming
to the mac but it still hasn't after
over a year and a half so what if this
12 core chip is actually just the future
m2 pro chip that will be going into the
2023
mac models including a potential imac
pro because if you really think about it
apple has to keep upgrading the m1 pro
and max chips in the future with higher
core counts for the m2 pro the m3 pro
the m4 pro etc so the easiest path for
apple to improve performance in future
high-end mac models is to simply give
the next-gen chip another two
performance cores for a total of 12
cores inside of the m2 pro champ and if
it's true that this 12 core chip is just
the future m2 pro then everything is
still up in the air for the upcoming
high-end apple silicon imac and we
should for sure expect the m1 pro and
max chips and potentially maybe even the
new 20 core m1 max duo although we don't
have concrete evidence for it just yet
but then what if there's a chance that
the high-end imac pro has been delayed
since dylan dkt did say that there were
some concerns with regards to production
so what if this 12 core chip is actually
destined for the upcoming imac pro but
it ends up getting delayed until maybe
wwdc or september when they would be
ready to reveal this new m2 pro chip but
once again it wouldn't make sense to
reveal the new m2 pro if they're
planning on releasing a new mac pro in
the fall or winter with an m1 max based
champ so all of this is really confusing
but in my personal opinion if i were to
take all of this info and combine it
together i think the most likely
scenario is that we do get a new
high-end imac at the spring event and
the new 12 chord ship will be destined
for the upcoming imac pro either later
this year or going into next year and i
know that's a disappointing scenario but
it's the most realistic and conservative
having the least amount of expectations
from apple and don't forget that the 20
core m1 max duo is still a possibility
for the imac which will hopefully be
coming this spring so with that said if
you completely disagree with all my
thoughts on this then go ahead and
comment down below but if you enjoyed
the video tap the like button and click
the circle about to subscribe for more
videos like this one and definitely
check out one of those two right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]